we love to spotlight amazing dads on
this show
and our next dad is a halloween hero
this is gdp good dad program
okay this story comes out of cincinnati
where one brave dad
engineered a trick-or-treat solution for
the coveted age
and here to tell us all about it please
welcome
andrew batey hi drew how are you hi
oh i was going to say the same thing to
you thank you so much for coming on now
your story is getting picked up
everywhere so we're really lucky that
you came
and will talk to us about it and we
i feel like i'm the lucky one but thank
you so much oh thank you andrew
andrew drew cool anyway
i always do that with an andrew and i
love it because my name's like a boy's
name
but um i just get excited when i hear it
um
it's no surprise that the cdc is like
officially called off trick-or-treating
and they've called it a high-risk
activity
but you have found a way to lower the
risks
so will you tell us about it absolutely
i'd be happy to
so you know my wife and i we have a
six-year-old daughter at home and
we really love doing creative things
activities that we can do together that
are fun
and safe and you know this year and
really any year
practicing safety guidelines when
trick-or-treating is really important
but especially with coven 19 this year
was more important than ever to give
people an
opportunity to maintain those social
distancing guidelines and
have some fun with it along the way and
this was something that we thought would
be a really great way to do so
so we used a six foot by four inch
shipping tube that we had laying around
we had played with dropping some toys
down and my wife and daughter and i
painted it up orange put some black duct
tape around it and lit it up and
put it on our rail to give it a test run
and it just seemed to really work really
well
and people are freaking out about it and
what i love is that you got something so
convenient and attainable this is not a
you know
rube goldberg contraption that people
cannot build
it's like this is doable for people and
i have to say that i
as a parent i feel sort of rattled when
my kids ask me how is halloween going to
function this year are we going to get
candy are we going to go
trick-or-treating
and i know for each sort of you know
area
within our country there are different
sets of guidelines
and we're always trying to
overcompensate for our kids anyway
and i think you've come up with
something that feels really safe
and doable for parents and
you really put the spirit back in
halloween and made it a little less
difficult for us parents to navigate
thank you so much you know we really
wanted to do something that could allow
everyone to participate
even those with mobility challenges this
is something that we've been talking
about doing for years you know you have
those moms with strollers or your people
in wheelchairs that
have to stop and think about how they
can participate the same way other
people do without having to stop and
think about it and that seems really you
know unfair to me with something like
this so this is something that
doesn't just scratch that one edge it's
something that really i think helps a
lot of people
regardless of whether or not we're
dealing with a pandemic so thank you
i have to say andrew i think you're
uh bringing all the goodness to the name
drew today
i'm i'm honored that i get that moniker
too because you really are
bringing you know the positivity and the
functionality here
for my favorite holiday of the year by
the way too
halloween you don't have to have you
don't have to travel it's you don't have
family baggage you don't have to get a
gift it's just the best i love halloween
so thank you andrew thank you you're
welcome
okay everybody thank you so much
[Music]